you have another [ __ ] phone give me
another phone another he's gone random
one give the name who is this
it went to a different number than the
one I was trying to call so knows
numbers no idea now I was trying to call
this one you better find the number
first let's see if they pick up those
things no you can't answer here no one
picks up like unknown numbers and you go
ha what area code is this what is it -
next time I can let it ring and tell
either there's an answer or no answer
and give that's the spawner no it's not
hey congratulations you won the spot no
George the spot winners a I think the
Google Voice sent to the to the other
number so it looked like the other
number so if you listened to me I was
trying to interrupt but I didn't want to
interrupt your genius sir so I never
that's hilarious what they may or may
not they may or may not have won sorry
about that voicemail that was Bobby
called me give you a real legit number
man is this another spot winner let's
not all make him spa winners what's on
your someone calling me a spy what is
calling back
it's on my feet I heard what it's coming
to both of us oh my god kalila Oh small
winner yeah it's Bobby Lee but I need I
need the person that's gonna win the spa
yeah it's gotta be a man yeah they don't
allow women in a spa those ones named
Steve is he a fan of the show or is it
some random I know I love touching
people well maybe I'll go to your what
your boyfriend's name is Steve is he
there with you all right well I want you
to give him this message then okay but
everything I say right now you have to
memorize this is you just hear me out or
I just listen to what I have to say all
right ready
ready you're the wonderful winner of the
fantastic spa experience I'm leaving bye
I don't know what else to say she
freaked me out oh yeah who's giggly no
well you know we'll make that up anybody
who calls the Google Voice it comes to
your phone as well okay got it Joe
yeah I'm Mike your real producer Joe
your real producer
[Music]